[Music]
action
um okay let me think how do I start this
one even though I said action one sec
show that I expected thank you
okay well the thing I was trying to
figure out what to say is that I had
this article front of me that they're
talking about how there is this very
mysterious complication happening with
coronavirus patients where they are
experiencing blood clotting and it's
actually accelerating how like the
complications of the disease are like
the virus and so oh no yeah and it's
crazy because they're giving these
patients anticoagulants and it's still
not working does that have anything to
do with quaaludes cause it kind of
sounds similar coagulants the blood okay
what I think you said it correctly when
your blood is like very thick right so
it's anti it's like yeah like a blood
thinner
it makes the jello go away I don't try
to quaaludes one day though exist
anymore
should exist somewhere oh yeah I don't
know did you buy and get some that [ __ ]
yep Dubai would be the place ask Bill
Cosby and then get in a Lamborghini
just like Leonardo DiCaprio in the movie
I like that and I'm bringing it to the
old school once or it's like you know I
tried to ask Bill Cosby then I fall
asleep my bubble fell for I took a bite
of that jello and I woke up in his hotel
room
I wasn't even tired who knows yeah I
guess so I guess seems a little boring
anyway back to the blood clot so what
they're saying here is that with corona
virus they are actually seeing something
that now they have called Co vid toes
Cova toes yeah in young people
so in asymptomatic patients it's
particularly younger people they have
noticed that sometimes the only symptom
that they have is that they have been
seeing these lesions in the feet so and
by younger people you may like under 18
or like
under like I don't know like 20 nan
boomer right like a while oh so they're
getting these lesions which that looks
like a hole last night out of Vegas and
high-heeled that just from Corona or
from the way that they're treating for
honor no so they're saying that this is
a symptom this is this is a symptom that
pops up in in a patient that has no
other symptoms like no fever no cough
nothing but they know that they have
corona because of this that's from the
coagulate coagulation and the toes like
blood Claudia yes I think that that and
they tested positive for Corona and then
they get Wow so like that's the only
symptom is [ __ ] up feet nervous or
anything they're saying that it it will
disappear within 10 days sometimes like
for some people can they still put on
finger socks no cuz I pictured it in my
mind are you thinking about those little
finger condoms no like you know some
people they got the toe sock yeah oh
yeah
the girls all have those yeah yeah
because it kids affection one of the
finger condoms when you're doing like
work and you look at the finger shoes
they know the vibrators yeah what do
they think it is - okay so they're
saying that based on how these corona
virus patients are being treated there's
there's these complications that are
happening where like if patients are
given blood thinners then it's causing
an imbalance in their blood and so what
happens here is it could easily turn
into severe clots where there's a
shit-ton of clots in this patient now
and these clots can move to the heart or
the brain and cause death and it just
would really complicate patients are in
the ICU and they're even saying that
they're clogging dialysis machines which
a dialysis machine and filters
impurities in the blood when the kidneys
are failing so there's been a lot of
dialysis
have been getting the genes were like
[ __ ] this it's too thick it's too crazy
right so then and then so like they
tried to treat it and it's like a fine
like balance because if they go too far
the other way then instead of blood
clots they end up like hemorrhaging like
profusely bleeding bleeding out cuz it's
not clotting at all no yeah so there's
like this really interesting thing
happening here is this like the [ __ ]
virus of all [ __ ] like there's so
much [ __ ] that's going on and it hits
people differently yeah and they're
saying that there have been I recently
read that there's like like 10 and new
strands from this one particular
coronavirus so like it's like it's
mutating mutating it's getting crazier I
just read that at least 3 million people
in New York have had coronavirus because
they just did that antibody survey over
they had it already had it already which
is crazy to think about but it actually
doesn't help to cuz I was reading it
also like people who have had it there's
a third you could have it again also
getting it again yeah but what's wild is
that LA we've had such a less rate
compared to New York way less and I have
a feeling that we all had coronavirus
back in December we covered that last
run our yeah it's well Stanford
University is doing a test right now and
seeing how many people have antibodies
yeah that'll be interesting to see if we
already have antibodies because then
that tells you a lot I think I had
Corona how about you guys I did I really
do that
I found test kits online for like a
hundred bucks I was like I don't know if
I want to spend a hundred bucks on this
if you have it now cuz then you I think
the one you want is to see if you have
the antibodies right yeah yeah Christmas
Eve last December and Christmas Day is
the sickest I have been in at least a
decade that I can like I was Sam but
after we shot danger boy there but did
you guys have corona like symptoms yeah
I did yeah I had a cop for a month we do
really yeah that's different
yeah it was a dry cough I was coughing
so hard I couldn't sleep yeah yeah your
yours seemed like you're with some [ __ ]
like that but none of you guys got it
and I saw old people and they didn't die
so what about not then like to be honest
well we don't have an exact
understanding yet of everything right
like even like what we're seeing here
like there's some people were
asymptomatic who had corona or there's
some people have mild fevers like I just
Alba had had Corona and he really didn't
have a tough time Tom Hanks had a he had
a tougher time so we don't really know
yet
yeah manifests differently in everybody
yeah did you guys get covert toys toes
when I heard this I was a little bit
concerned because my big toes yeah check
that no it doesn't look any different
but like I can't feel the end of it in
my big toe oh there's your lady circuit
oh no I only realize it's like a few
weeks ago and I was like I can't feel
these yeah me too I for this I don't
know four years not three years for me
was recently because we were cutting a
buck by cardboard boxes and I think I
damaged a nerve from using the box
cutter cuz I was pretty aggressive with
it and like for good now I have feeling
I could feel it but it like [ __ ] up my
index finger along to are completely
[ __ ] numb and then I go these two
away ah so so you gotta be careful with
how you throw again sighs it ya know
it's helping him know so here's an
appetite when I used to live in
Koreatown
I was walking I used to have to park it
four blocks away from my place because I
there's no [ __ ] parking in every
towns the waters rough and then I have
so many [ __ ] grocery bag like plastic
bags dig it into my fingers when I was
walking back you know your fingers feel
like sparklers we go on oh yeah yeah and
then once I got all the way there and
like got my key and put it all in and
[ __ ] like these never got quite the same
feeling back you like that ends up
happening like I think that I have
permanent damage in the tip of this
finger because it's already been two
weeks I still can't feel just cutting
the cardboard boxes and then so what
ended up happening is I could feel like
if I move my wrist Oh like right now
what happened like if I move it a
particular way I could feel like a nerve
like like Twitter from yeah like he's
shooting up and then it goes like from
although all the weight yeah well I have
something like that yeah thank you so
k-town I lived there 2007 long time so
these nurses is dead right but then I
also fell asleep on my hand I've talked
about this before yeah and I fell asleep
on it so hard that my wrist was like
this for like [ __ ] four months and
it's true it's so true I could picture
my family was there and like I had
[ __ ] I couldn't Drive really like it
was not and so when I do weights when I
do weights and [ __ ] I could do this
right like you could extend your elbow
yeah oh that shit's fine but but my but
this buddy was like this the whole time
Thank You Rex arm for like really no no
it was just this the wrist just the
wrist so I liked him liked it I could
not lift it at all and my whole family
thought I was [ __ ] clown around them
and [ __ ] but this this wrist while I was
able to get my nerves back in a lot [ __ ]
it's not nearly as strong as this guy
like nerve nerve Dan and you're you're
right-handed I'm right-handed and your
right wrist is not even nearly Wow like
when I'm weightlifting I can always do a
couple more on this body with my like
pretty severe cramp in ninth grade crap
[ __ ] up all your name Oh cramp
I got a cramp right here what is this
called you can't yeah yeah I had one of
those and since then like till this date
like I could if I'm working out or
whatever
I'm way more flexible with my right leg
that would probably build nerves back or
like you killed it up or sensitivity or
whatever it's nerves are unpredictable
so like Peyton Manning dealt with this
cuz he had a surgery and then he was
never able to quite get his exact well
at least he was able to build his
strength back but then his strength
deteriorated faster because of nerve
damage is so [ __ ] strange because I
heard that you can build nerves by
focusing on like objects and like like
awareness and sending just mental like
importance in that after I did didn't
physical therapy they have you doing
there
and I added that for months but it was
still like god never as the same as
whatever the same well it was all so
silly that I've talked about this before
but is so silly because I'm in there and
I have like you know I'm I fell asleep
in my hand and those guys in there who
lost their limbs in Iraq and you you
said they're right here like so what you
in here but yeah right you know I slept
on my arm I felt my head but these cats
were like yeah man Afghanistan second
tour and I'm like oh my god I'm with
Heroes Lilly up there remember the night
I ate jack-in-the-box
I watched Superman - I fell asleep
that's it wake up this is gone for four
house that's Marie and that's what you
tell hero is that bird right these guys
like I was in Fallujah nobody's [ __ ]
coming back up cancelled what do I do I
jump on the grenade or whatever these
cats are [ __ ] legends in there what
did you do react in a box and fell
asleep - tacos - Jack of the Box I jumbo
jack with fries and then yeah I watched
Superman - of Christopher Reeves and I
did you tell them that you found the
water protect people like me I didn't
have the balls I thank you for your
service Toto thanks to you I can go eat
at Jack in a box you can fall asleep in
my hand walking here today and then I'm
like well technically I can't eat jugnu
bucks right now right handed I can't
really eat tacos in left
did you salute them like this thank you
for your service thank you for your
service sir thank you my entire family's
mojo I hope you never see this video
[Music]